Today, I'm going to show you how to add a Persistent Disk to your Linux VM
Open the Google Developer's Console, and go to the  'VM Instances' screen.
Click the instance
Scroll down to the 'Additional disks' section
Click 'Edit', now click 'Add item', 'Select a Disk', 'Create new Disk'
Now, give it a Name, select the Type, choose 'Blank Disk', specify the size, and click 'Create'
Now click save
Now SSH into your machine
Get the name of the disk by using the 'lsblk' command
Now make a new directory to mount your disk.
Now, we can use the 'safe_format_and_mount' tool to mount the disk
Specify the disk name, and the name of the directory we just created, and hit enter
In a few minutes, the disk is formatted and mounted!
We can use the 'lsblk' command again to see the disk is correctly mounted